for the tampa bay rays this afternoon
it's going to be left-hander josh
fleming making his third start
of the season fourth overall game the
season numbers outside of the record and
that is a
that is a hard luck record you see that
era 1.23 and how about this duane
10 games seven starts as a member of the
raids going back
to the 2020 season and he has given up
one earned run or fewer
in seven of the ten jose altuve as you
can see is over his last 14 after
coming off the il4 for eight ended the
night oh for five but that quickly
changes today first pitch swinging out
tuva hits a line drive down the right
field line
and jose altuve on the first pitch has a
stand-up double
looks like that even surprised jose
altuve because this is exactly what you
want to do against the sinker baller
that you're facing that two seamer
running away on our mattress from super
mode he just keeps his head down on it
goes with it the other way
front side kind of opened up a little
bit but that barrel lagged right through
the zone and shot it the other way with
some authority and lead off man and
scoring position
altuve on second with one out here is
alex bregman bregman hit a two run home
run last night home run number four on
the season also had an infield hit
bregman hits one to right field down the
line a rose arena long run he won't get
there altuve around third he's going to
score
alex bregman an rbi single astros on the
board the first inning just like last
night it's one to nothing
beautiful start to the game and a 3-1
count didn't exactly crush that baseball
but found
a perfect plot of land out there that
sinker going away from him gets it off
the end of the bat
and the bases will be loaded for yuliy
guriel welcome back julie
yoli line drive into right field that's
a base hit
in the score bregman alvarez being waved
home the throw is not in time
two rbi single for uli garielle astros
out in front three to nothing so we've
talked a little bit about fleming being
high on the sinking fastball
yulia is a hitter that goes the other
way extremely well so this is a little
bit of an ambush knowing that he's
probably going to get a sinker in the
zone to start this at bat after falling
behind the last two hitters and walking
them
that is just a salty veteran sitting on
deck realizing an opportunity with the
bases juice to get a good pitch to hit
took advantage of it and just got a base
hit out of it and drove in a couple of
runs
jordan flying and now the count's full
three and two to the left-handed band of
kyle tucker
and a cut and a foul tip right back into
the middle of cenino
for the strikeout and out number two
well just went right after him through
the sinker 92
outer half and down got tucker to pull
right off of it here is
miles straw 212 on the year
and that is strike three call he got the
corner that time
back in tampa you see the astros have
that three to nothing lead over the
tampa bay rays jose or kitty the
benefactor of that will be starting this
game for the houston astros
margot ball back over the mound right
back over in second
and bobble there by altuve and margot
is aboard altuve dwayne he's got a good
internal clock and realizing that that
ball was not hit that hard he was trying
to get ready to throw this ball before
he actually failed him
he was trying to he was already thinking
about get
getting this ball on its way with the
speed of margot and look at that even
his throwing hand got into the glove
before the ball deck
margo is going to get a hit out of that
redmond has been a tough out against a
lot of teams and
the raves have felt their share of it
little number
bare-handed nice pick up there by
fleming and he runs it in to make the
play unassisted
they had yandee diaz closing in on that
little tap
and that's a nice play indeed by fleming
yeah and the reason dwayne right here
watch yandy diaz he is going to leave
the bag
so i'll tell you he's going after the
ball so is fleming
now fleming grabs this and looks up for
help at first it's not there
and so he's got a bare-handed and then
make his way to the bag
by himself nice athletic play by the ray
starter
well you want to keep that first hitter
of an ending off the bases
you're don alvarez now the count is full
sweet and to miss he's out on strikes
two up two down
yeah that that's incredible you know 30
30 guy right out of the gate not for the
season
for the first hundy you start to think
about
you know could you imagine rolling into
the big leagues of being a 40-40 guy
right out of the gate
give him a you know 162.
carlos correa sends a fly ball
into center margot is lined up to catch
it and it's a one two three third
adamus went on to say that he'd rather
the slump happen now than later in the
season
and that he thinks he can make an
adjustment and this can help boost
his performance at the plate because he
said he really missed touching first
base
and i guess that hit was good luck guys
well he's gonna touch it again
as he goes after the first pitch and
singles with a line drive into left
so there you go you'd love to see that
become contagious
up and down the lineup really has a
single his first time up today well
artedi
you know with that fastball just kind of
left it out over the plate right into
the
swing there of adamus here's mike zunino
gets owen too
herkidi picks up a three-pitch strikeout
of zanino his first strikeout of the
game
through the get me over slider the
previous pitch but this one was to go
out there and get that swing and miss if
he can
nurture that right there and become more
consistent with it that'd be a nice
little wrinkle to have in a two-strike
count to right-handed hitters that was
the pitch that was missing in colorado
when he got hit around a little bit
completely
here's austin meadows 2-2 pitch is a
swing and a miss top of the zone or
kitty
picking up back-to-back strikeouts
getting zanino and now austin meadows
finally got austin meadows in a
two-strike count had to go to the
four-seamer up and in
you can see maldonado set up right there
and he hits the target and gets the
swing and miss that was beautifully done
by her kitty
couple of changeups down down and away
before that pitch
there's one away now for randy a
rosarian man this guy
nice pick by bregman on the backhand
there's a high throw but yuli takes care
of it we're the second out
makes it look easy that's a little foot
adjustment there on a high throw too
yep get out of the way of the base
runner make sure the play is made it's a
good visual of the footwork for alex
bregman
coming in to get that short hop just a
little bit up but not enough for julie
to come off the back
seven innings out of her kitty today as
taking over here in the eighth inning
facing the nine one and two hitters is
brooks raley
this will be his 13th appearance the era
elevated at 7.36
facing mike zanino who struck out twice
as paul in on the hands of zanino
bregman
will make the play in time to get tampa
bay catcher for the first out of the
eighth inning
rosso will hit here for austin meadows
swing and a miss
brooks raleigh picking up a strikeout of
brasso the pinch hitter and there's two
away
two outs base is clear here's manuel
margot swing and a miss
got him with the fastball tailing away
margot goes down
swinging brooks rayleigh two strikeouts
in the inning
we're gonna head to the ninth with the
astros leading three to nothing
well here's brandon lau and a ground
ball gonna be a base hit
through the left side well they left
just one man over there
leaving bregman by himself and brandon
lau picks up his second hit of the game
he got it by
bregman well right here that's the
number one
the one guy on the right side left side
he was able to work it back by the way
to get that fastball
and hit it the other way you know
presley was pretty sharp with the
curveball
right out of the gate one out with two
on and here is yandy diaz
two men in scoring position now with
diaz
he has a ground ball headed toward the
middle over to make the pick up
correa in the throw is in time the rays
get a run
lau crosses the plate rosarina goes to
third
here it is that ball down the way off
the end of the bat correa able to get to
it and then float the throw
rays do get a run but they're down to
their final out it's a two-run ball game
second game in a row the astros taking a
shutout into the ninth inning yoshi
susugo
sharply hit altuve backhands the play to
first on the bounce in time for the
final out of this game
good play by jose altuve and julie
guriel to wrap this one up the astros
hold on to win
3-1 ryan presley picks up his fourth
save of the year